.
>> Will: THANKS FOR THAT
REPORT.
BRAND-NEW FOX POLL TONIGHT AS
WELL SHOWING 87% OF REGISTERED
VOTERS ARE EXTREMELY OR VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT INFLATION OR
HIGHER PRICES.
MEANWHILE, 76% CARE ABOUT DEEP
POLITICAL DIVISIONS AND ALMOST
THE VERY BOTTOM OF THE LIST, IF
YOU CAN LOOK DOWN THAT FAR, ONLY
65% ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHY IS THAT THE ONLY THING
JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS SEEM
TO CARE ABOUT?
IT'S LIKE THEY FLIPPED THE POLE
UPSIDE DOWN.
HERE NOW, NEWT GINGRICH FORMER
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
HE'S GOT A NEW BOOK, BEYOND
BIDEN OUT ON NOVEMBER 2ND, YOU
CAN PREORDER YOUR COPY NOW ON
AMAZON.
GLAD TO HAVE YOU, YOU CAN SEE
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO AMERICANS,
WHY IS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ON INTERESTED IN THOSE ISSUES?
>> THAT'S TRUE ACROSS THE BOARD,
THEY AREN'T INTERESTED IN
CONTROLLING THE BORDER WHICH IS
A HUGE ISSUE FOR AMERICANS, THEY
ARE UNINTERESTED IN THE RISE IN
MURDERERS WHICH IS A BIG ISSUE
FOR AMERICANS, YOU COULD GO
THROUGH THE WHOLE LIST OF
THINGS.
THE BIDEN TEAM WHICH INCLUDES
SCHUMER AND PELOSI AND EVERY
DEMOCRAT IN WASHINGTON EXCEPT
MAYBE JOE MANCHIN AND
KYRSTEN SINEMA, THEY ARE
COMMITTED TO A HARD LEFT BIG
GOVERNMENT SOCIALIST MODEL.
THEY HAVE TO PAY OFF THE UNIONS,
THEY'VE GOT TO PASS BIG
SPENDING.
THEY'VE GOT TO FIND WAYS TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR ALLIES AND I THINK
THAT YOU SEE THEM LITERALLY
TONE-DEAF.
I DON'T HAVE THE LANGUAGE -- AND
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO REJECT
REALITY.
REAGAN USED TO SAY YOU DIDN'T
WORRY ABOUT WHAT LIBERALS DIDN'T
KNOW, HE WORRIED ABOUT WHAT THEY
KNEW THAT WASN'T TRUE.
NOW I'M WORRIED BECAUSE EVEN
WHEN IT'S OBJECTIVELY OBVIOUS,
THEY ARE FLYING CHILDREN AT
NIGHT INTO WESTCHESTER COUNTY,
NEW YORK, GETTING THEM OUT OF
TEXAS AND I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
KNOWS WHERE THEY'RE GOING,
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THEM AND THE
WHITE HOUSE IS JUST TOTALLY OUT
OF TOUCH WITH REALITY AND
FRANKLY SO IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN THE HOUSE IN
THE SENATE.
>> Will: WE WILL HAVE TO HAVE
A LONGER CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE I'M FASCINATED ABOUT
WHAT YOU SAID TO.
I STRUGGLE WITH THE LANGUAGE AS
WELL.
I THINK THEY ARE DEVELOPING A
PSEUDO-REALITY, THEY HAVE
MANIPULATED SO SUCCESSFULLY
THERE IS NO NEED TO ADAPT TO
WHAT THEY THINK IS THE REAL
REALITY.
THIS MUCH MORE HERE BUT I NEED
TO ASK YOU ABOUT A NEW STORY AS
WELL.
NEW REPORT OUT DEMOCRATIC DONORS
SEE THIS REALITY.
JOE BIDEN HAS NO FUTURE
POLITICALLY, KAMALA HARRIS HAS
NO FUTURE POLITICALLY AND
DEMOCRATIC DONORS ARE NOW
LOOKING TO PETE BUTTIGIEG AS THE
POSSIBLE FUTURE MAY BE AS EARLY
AS 2024.
HOW IS THAT FOR REALITY?
>> YOU'VE GOT IN PETE BUTTIGIEG
SOMEBODY WHO TOOK TWO MONTHS OFF
ON FAMILY LEAVE LEAVING BEHIND
NOBODY IN CHARGE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION AS
WE DRIFTED INTO A GIGANTIC
CRISIS OF LOGISTICS WITH OVER 60
SHIPS STUCK OFFSHORE FROM
LONG BEACH, OFF OF SAVANNA COME
OFF OF LOS ANGELES, YOU CAN TAKE
A GUY WHO WAS A TOTAL FAILURE AT
SOLVING ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ECONOMIC PROBLEMS WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW AND WE ARE GOING TO SOMEHOW
MAGICALLY MAKE HIM THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
AS A REPUBLICAN, I THINK IT'S
TERRIFIC.
AS A MATTER -- AS A MATTER OF
REALITY, HOW CAN YOU TAKE THIS
GUY WHO'S UTTERLY IRRESPONSIBLE
AND THERE'S A CERTAIN LEVEL
WHERE FAMILY LEAVE DOESN'T QUITE
WORK WHERE IF YOU ARE IN CHARGE
OF THE WHOLE COUNTRY'S
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
HE DIDN'T LEAVE ANYBODY IN
CHARGE.
FOR TWO MONTHS WE WERE
RUDDERLESS, HAD NOBODY IN CHARGE
AND THE ENTIRE LOGISTICS SYSTEM
GOT STEADILY WORSE AS WE ARE
GOING TO DISCOVER THAT
CHRISTMAS.
>> Will: I CAN SYMPATHIZE WITH
HIM A LITTLE BIT, I DON'T KNOW
WHERE ELSE THEY WOULD TURN, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE THEY WOULD
GO.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU GO?
>> THEY GOT LOTS OF PEOPLE, THEY
GOT SENATORS, THEY GOT
GOVERNORS, THEY GOT MOVIE STARS.
SOMEWHERE OUT THERE, THERE'S
SOMEBODY BETTER THAN